wir haben ja bei der heute schon immer
so getan als könnte man sie nicht
verstehen haben untertitel darunter
gemacht das war sich lächerlich aber
damit habe es jetzt nicht
[Musik]
hallo auf berlin heutigen von mir keine
blöde witze
heute gibt es nur ein sorry fdp
[Musik]
gestern
da
[Musik]
hier ist ein kleines märchen zur
anschuldigungen dankend annehmen sie
nicht an das pärchen nein das schickte
sie mal lieber
schenken sie mal lieber irgendjemandem
das wirklich nötig an sie sehen mich
charakterlich gefestigt dem rösler also
irgendwie immer in denen sie richtig
gern haben wir 16 sein
das glaube ich hier nicht nur ehrlich zu
sein war er führt wieder gab es auch
immer die stimme der vernunft auf die
leider nie gehört wurde hier ist sie
hallo herr anfrage kurs halten
er hat sozusagen unterstützen so dass
ich vor kurzem jetzt nach 40 jährigen
warten um den wandel vorschlag von baden
württemberg gewählt worden
das gibt's doch nicht alles wegen der
heute show ich vermute ja die jahren
vermutet dass es daher war sind weil das
mein bekanntheitsgrad dermaßen erhöht
hat gut das haben wir auch nicht gewollt
war
sind sie bereit hält er hat für eine
ernst gemeinte entschuldigung
hier sollen
hallo sie sind im neuen landtag
vertreten was ist ihre strategie um auch
da wieder raus zu fliegen
es soll die idee welche fragen
also sie wollen erst die europawahl
vergeigen oder wir haben ja bei der
heute schon immer so getan als könnte
man sie nicht verstehen haben untertitel
drunter gemacht das war sich lächerlich
aber damit habe es jetzt nicht akustisch
nicht verstanden sagt er es war schon
gut gemacht ich habe es nicht bereut ich
würde auch gern meinen arm nehmen ich
würde jedoch auch gern bei den arm
nehmen unschuldigen sagen wollen sie
mich nicht gerade meinen arm nehmen herr
rösler
ich hoffe er lindner sie vergessen auch
in zukunft nicht den sie zu verdanken
haben dass der rösler endlich weg ist
können sie das versprechen das sie dann
immer noch mit mir reden wenn sie
parteivorsitz
ich glaube eben denn die fdp hat ja
bisher jedes versprechen gehalten
herr kubicki wir treffen uns hier immer
wieder bei den usern von der fdp das
haben wir beide doch eigentlich gar
nicht nötig oder das stimmt wir möchten
uns im rahmen der heute schon bei ihnen
entschuldigen zahl den mist den wir
gemacht haben
es war hart das war kindisch ist das
schlimm aber lustig war es die
entschuldigung wenn ich an die wende
eintreten weil das doch ein gutes
zeichen denn weiß es doch sagen wusste
ich dass dies ganz nur für freunde ich
habe immer das große glück dass der
bundesparteitag ich die hände von
journalistinnen und journalisten falle
beim letzten mal was frau himmelreich
heute was nutzt van der horst das ist
dieser puscheligen reporter von heute
show er kam zu mir sagt er blicke ich
will mich bei ihnen entschuldigen die
heute show ist mit der fdp wirklich
miserabel umgang der vergangenheit und
hatten wir dafür ein bärchen gegeben
nahm ich gesagt ich will sie jetzt mehr
ernst nehmen wenn sie das wirklich ernst
meinen treten sie heute in die fdp ein
[Musik]
ich bin hier
[Applaus]
ich habe natürlich nicht meinen namen
braucht geschrieben sondern dem vom werk
in spe nicht verrückt und damit zurück
nach köln
[Applaus]
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbol ihr bei uns im neuen studio
gefunden
illuminati freimaurer staatsführung ist
alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekanntgeben
er ist ein so viele abonnenten auf
youtube also ich würde mich ran halten